okay so we've got national polls and
state polls and we have an electoral
college system in the United States
doesn't matter if you win the popular
vote in the sense that you can win the
popular vote and lose the election as
Hillary Clinton did in 2016 you can also
lose the popular vote and win the
election as Donald Trump did in 2016
well the Trump campaign is looking at
the 2020 electoral map and they're
panicking because what they see is
really not good now I want to give mine
so this is getting really interesting
and I want to dig into the data but I do
feel the need to remind everybody a lot
can change in five months just because
this is where things are today does not
mean that this is where things will be
in five months Trump could end up
winning this reelection in a huge
landslide we all need to vote etc okay
now there are only so many paths to
victory for any one candidate the paths
to victory are a little bit different
electoral e for democrats than they are
for republicans in our electoral college
system only some states are in play so
in November California and Massachusetts
are going to vote for Joe Biden North
and South Dakota and Wyoming are going
to vote for Donald Trump and once you
start kind of crossing off the blue
states that will definitely go Biden and
the red states that will definitely go
for Trump you start to get a set of what
we call battleground states that are the
state's more likely to make a difference
in the election so Massachusetts has a
very small chance of being the decider
between Trump and Biden it's going to go
to Biden and it is not going to be the
state that influences who gets to 270
electoral votes there are states that
Trump carried easily in 2016 where he is
not doing so well and this presents a
real problem for Trump in his path to
270 electoral votes Arizona is a state
from one in 2016 where he's not doing
well right now
Georgia is almost certain to still go to
Donald Trump but Trump is actually
having to spend some money in Georgia a
state that Republicans often don't have
to spend money in we've had these
national polls where Trump is losing to
Biden by 6 7 even 11 in the latest
Monmouth poll Monmouth poll very highly
rated by fivethirtyeight.com
but again the national picture is one
thing to get a real sense you have to
look state-by-state so check out some of
these examples in 2016 Trump won Arizona
by three and a half Biden's up by almost
three that's a six and a half point
swing against Trump in Arizona Florida
Trump won by one point two percent in
2016
Biden is currently leading by three
point four that's almost a five point
swing in Florida very important state in
Iowa
Trump won by almost 10 and he's up by
under five that's a five point swing
against Trump in Iowa Ohio massively
important to Republicans I'll explain
why in a moment
Trump won by eight in 2016
Biden is currently leading by one and
Wisconsin which was one of that tree one
of the the the trio of states that
handed the victory to Trump that were
reasonable states that Hillary Clinton
could have won Trump won Wisconsin by
half a point last election Biden
currently winning by three point four so
Florida and Ohio are massively important
because they have a ton of electoral
votes and because they are often the
states that when a Republican loses them
they end up losing the election so five
point swing and Florida nine point swing
in Ohio away from Donald Trump and
here's why it matters go to 270 to win
calm and start with the 2016 map it is
really difficult for Trump to have a
path to victory without Ohio
if only Ohio and Florida flip to Biden
Biden wins and it's over doesn't matter
what happens in other states if Trump
keeps Florida but loses Ohio Biden can
still win by flipping Arizona and
Wisconsin where he's leading Wisconsin
in Michigan where he's leading or
Michigan and Arizona where he's leading
even just Pennsylvania in addition to
getting Ohio loses it for Donald Trump
this is why Ohio is so important for
Donald Trump and and has been important
for Republican presidents in general
never mind
some of these other states now at the
tail end of this even if Trump keeps
Ohio in Florida which he's currently
losing but imagine that Ohio and Florida
go
back to Donald Trump and he wins them in
November Biden can still win by flipping
Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania all
of which looked pretty good for him
right now or Pennsylvania Michigan in
Arizona
you get the idea holding every 2016
state is very important for Trump he
really can't afford to lose very much
you can go to 270 to win calm right now
run the combinations yourself now
meanwhile Trump's disapproval rating has
hit a six-month high dating all the way
back to November small moves but still
significant to some degrees so here's
what this means absolutely nothing in
terms of whether you should vote in
November we've got to keep up the
pressure Donald Trump here's I think the
most important point I want to make what
Donald Trump has done up until now
should already preclude him from being
reelected you know if Trump cures cancer
and eliminates poverty in the next five
months come talk to me and then you know
maybe we'll have a different perspective
from what has already happened Donald
Trump deserves to be removed now we have
five months during which we need to keep
the pressure up if the polls remain as
they are Trump will lose and we will
remove what what may be one of the
gravest national electoral errors in the
history of this country
if the pressure lets up the economy
starts to sort of look like it might be
in recovery
it's conceivable that Donald Trump will
get himself reelected and so this is a
snapshot today we need to continue and
we need to keep it up make sure you are
following the show on facebook at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show we
have been live streaming on Facebook as
well I'll see you there or in just two
minutes on the other side of this break